I don't know what to say you were on the
program we looked at a lot of footage
and you described in great detail what
you were doing and then I you know I
like you I begged you please be careful
and I know that you are careful and then
something I guess this last time around
went went very wrong what happened a
momentary lapse in judgment
I basically was aiming for some balloons
and aiming for balloons what were the
balloons doing there
there were targets where were you
worried it just paint the picture for us
where were you you did a jump and we're
gonna towards it I was in South Africa
right and I was filming for HBO and we
were jumping off of Table Mountain which
is a jump that almost killed me 10 years
ago and basically I went back to kind of
you know conquer that demon that was so
terrifying for me because I had a really
bad experience right always unnecessary
by the way or have a terrifying
experience walk away and never go back
that's my rule well we have different
ideas okay but yours like that was
horrifying I almost died I must return
basically that's how I see it so I did
go back and I did five jumps that went
perfect and they went so well that I
decided let's you know do a little
further and deeper and then we put up
balloons for me to hit and put balloons
up on strings then and then you try and
touch the balloons and how far there are
the balloons off of the surface of the
raw ordinarily they're about six feet
high um but on this one my friend Joby
jumped first and when he flew over them
he blew the balloons with his air and
one of them flew lower and got hooked on
rocks and from where I was standing I
saw the two sets of balloons and I
decided to go for the lower one because
I thought it'd be more challenging and
you were correct it was more challenging
it was way more tell us no we'll look at
the crash in a second which I'm sure
must be fun for you uh what happened
what part of your body you go in and the
balloon is much lower than it should be
how fast you going I'm doing about 120
miles an hour and you're all you're
wearing is this flight suit yes and adds
no pads nothing and we're talking very
hard rock here this is a solid grind
this is not candy land this is not a
marshmallow mountain
because I do all my BASE jumping on
candy land and just fall into fudge what
what part of your body what happens so
what part of your body hit the rock I'm
flying and basically in order to do the
flight that I was trying to do because
the balloon was so low I basically lean
over and generate speed yes and I use
that speed to then create lift as I
plane out and I actually because the
balloon was so low I had to fly between
a boulder field so there were these
boulders and I was flying between the
boulders as I was coming to get the
actual balloon and as I was coming
between the boulders my left foot
clipped one of the boulders and it
drugged me into the ledge and there was
basically a flat granite ledge that the
balloon was sitting basically on and I
impacted the ledge at the waist and as I
impacted the wedge I just skipped off
the rock and it was bad yeah and your
your first thought was well my first
thought was that I was dead that I was
gonna die I really did think that you
wonder by it was I didn't think I pretty
much knew like I knew waters wet and I
knew the sky is blue I knew I was dead I
knew that my legs were crushed that I
was gonna bleed out and I was gonna die
I was 100% sure all right let's take a
look at this accident bit your point of
view obvious or this is a camera that's
attached to you yeah we're gonna see you
get way too low and then you're gonna
clip the rock and crash yeah
and now your knowing you're gonna crash
it why I have to keep flying if I had
deployed my parachute too soon I would
have impacted the top and died so I
actually had to regain regain continue
flying over the ledges until I got to an
area where I could actually open a
parachute okay
what were your injuries um I ended up it
actually turned out not being so bad I
thought it was gonna be way worse but it
end up just being two broken ankles a
broken fibula a torn ACL and I opened up
a massive gash in my shin that was so
spread that they had used skin grafts in
order to close it up nothing I do
difficult interviews all the time good
I'm just totally being an ass